hey it's Evan Carmichael and today I
wanted to share a great story about
someone who spammed me and and i managed
to help turn them around and realize
that you know you don't have to be
desperate in business you don't have to
spam people to get people to pay
attention to you don't they yell at them
you just got to be genuine authentic and
realize that you're doing something
important so here's the story is a guy
named Scott asked me my connection a
linkedin and I approved him and right
away I get a message back thank you for
accepting my friend request blah blah
blah have you ever been told that if you
ever see a once in lifetime opportunity
to grab it and run with it always talk
about making money quantifiable money in
your pocket not just perceive money blah
blah blah blah blah everybody needs is
product trust me there's like screaming
spam this is not what I want to see you
from people and it doesn't get results
you don't like I know you may be
frustrated and desperate and you're
you're trying to feed your family but
this isn't the way to do it so I wrote
back I was another message another spam
he wrote two is he wrote to spam
messages I wrote back to say come on
skype is serving people on LinkedIn
really working for you I know it's hard
getting people to sign up for something
new and you really want this thing to
work out for you but you focus in on the
wrong marketing if you want to have
success one people talking about you
right now all they're saying is Scott's
a spammer the key is to stand for
something what do you believe in that
will move people what is your strong
opinion that you need to share with the
world believe in it passionately share
your expertise create content that
people actually want to share and
they'll do it you'll give people come
into your website and signing up you'll
feel better about yourself and get way
better results wishing the best of luck
Scott I hate seen entrepreneurs struggle
especially when they have noble goals
and want to make a difference believe
Evan so this start an email thread okay
and the first one was a defensive excuse
me Evan why would i spend people if i
don't like being spammed your profile
says you number one believed in
entrepreneur but then you go and say
this about me spam rat should feel
offended with such accusations I stand
for a lot of integrity
belief and honor my company and product
I would love to set up a phone call and
talk with you right now the guy plainly
spam me okay he spam me full out and I
called him out on it and it's getting
defensive robot come on Scott I'm here
fighting for you I'm the only guy who
will back to you and it's trying to help
you even though you invaded my inbox you
sent me this message without customizing
it at all besides my name its
unsolicited you trying to sell me on
something how would you define spam I
believe you stand for something
LinkedIn's fame is beneath you it also
doesn't work stand up and show me what
you stand for make me want to talk about
you in a good way cheers evan believe he
writes back I think we got off on the
wrong foot Evan to be honest I hate
typing I'm not very good at it if rather
talked on the phone it's hard than
they're saying people's emotions through
email people can jump to conclusions so
I'd rather talk get to know you and
share our stories from rushing success
so we've turned it around a little bit
we've turned it around a little bit now
he's you know he's not being defensive
he's just blaming that he can't write
you know whatever made a mistake not
owning up to it but still it's on it's
on the path so I went back here we all
make mistakes I've made tons but if
you're defending your spam are going to
keep doing it than I have no interest in
helping you if you want my attention or
anybody else's you have to start by
giving me something to believe in what
does Scott Smith stand for that will
change the world why should I care make
me feel something if you're not going to
type in that's cool don't type make a
video recording a video clip this is
important Scott this is how you're going
to reach people is how you're going to
get people on board and changed their
lives otherwise people going to ignore
you he writes back this whole thing
telling me his life story this whole
thing so this is deeply emotional
personal we don't need to get through
but now I'm starting to open up right
now he's telling me why this is
important to him his family his
background right and this is not just
Scott's this is everybody story okay
you're struggling with your business
you're trying to get it going you know
you have bills to pay you try to put
food on the table and it's not happening
and so your default is a
I'm gonna go jump up some business i'm
going to go email people connect with as
many people linkedin as possible and
spread my message to them but you're
just wasting your time this is not the
way to build the business if you are not
authentic if you're not building
something that's important and nobody's
gonna care and shouting louder is not
going to help why am i helping Scott you
know I've got this message to a lot of
people who spam me and and he was the
main guy who wrote back a few others but
I like helping people who want to make a
difference in the world right that's why
I'm doing this and if if your responsive
and you you're open to change opening
the listened advice and I want to help
you that's what I do I believe in
entrepreneurs so Robox s is a great
start now crunch it down and make it
relate to your audience this is your
founding story it shaped everything and
moves people to trust you because you're
being vulnerable and are sharing what
you know works with people to make their
lives better hashtag on your way happy
face we're turning things around here he
writes back thanks Evan for your input
I'm working really hard to make my
family's and so many others dreams come
true if you have any more advice please
share as i'm very coachable hey we have
turned this man around this is great so
I said okay you want you want coaching
I'm going to give it to you here we go
do this make two videos one your
founding story why you are doing this
and why it's important basically what
you wrote to me but condensed make it
powerful make it mean something to a
strong opinion video tell me something
that is wrong in the world and how
people can fix it make it important make
it emotional do those and send it to me
know it'll take a while to do and you'll
feel like the video suck and they will
but it's how you start and I'll give you
feedback if you haven't spent at least
10 hours in each video preparing and
practicing recording and rerecording
don't send it to me hashtag honor system
this is for you any roads back awesome-o
get on it ASAP thank you so much he
wrote in to say will do so thanks again
for your support the videos are coming
along and they look horrible on camera
long anyways I'll keep you updated
cheers scott so I didn't hear from Scott
again and that's fine but it just
recently wrote to me and he said hello
Evan it's been a long time since we
connected I want to thank you for
inspiring me to make videos and believe
in myself as an entrepreneur
since then I've made many videos which
have received great feedback and I've
also made its way to Europe I have also
inspired someone to do the same I met a
person over in the UK and introduce them
to syntek global january i was given a
green light to open in the UK April this
year my business partner and i were
given a green light to open all 28
countries in the EU I'm now travelling
over there for 17 days to share my story
and to meet everyone that is joining
organisation anyways I want to give an
update but mainly to say thank you Scott
see how this guy's life has been turned
around you know here he was struggling
to get his business off the ground
connect with people on LinkedIn because
he probably read it at some marketing
strategy somewhere and then spamming
them to say join my network and he got
no results I was probably the only guy
who wrote back to him and I was
challenging him and he fought with me at
the start defending his spam and then
blaming it on not good typing and then
finally accepting coaching and doing the
videos doing the homework that I signed
him and look at what's happened like I'm
so proud of this guy now I'm so proud of
him he's making videos he's opening
opportunities he's helping people's
lives be better and it's great I
couldn't imagine a better result for him
and this is important for you guys too
but the whole point of sharing this is
having a teachable lesson for you right
if you're struggling with your business
you're trying to get something going
you're trying to jump up new business
you might be looking online for
strategies on how to get people now into
your company it's not going to come from
spamming people that's what you're doing
right now really look at your strategy
is it working are you actually getting
any results from this so you don't have
a lot to lose here share your story make
it important make me feel something if I
understand what you're trying to do and
why it's so important to you if i
connect to you that I'm much more likely
to take action to buy from you to refer
you to pass your name along anyway great
message that came in I was honored to be
able to help this guy out and I hope
through his lesson you're able to learn
as well let me know you guys sick leave
a comment below give it a thumbs up
click on my face got to the channel
thank you so much believe and I'll see
you soon
you